so art Calise asks do the laws of
physics really exist or are they just
mathematics that simplifies the complex
reality well I believe that the real
world the universe nature exists and
what we try to do is construct a model
or a picture or a theory of nature which
is an approximation always a provisional
explanation so far of that is an accord
and that we can test by is in accord
with our observations that we can test
by experiment so to some extent the laws
of physics that prove successful and are
well tested don't contradict observation
or experiment our models or reflections
of a something that truly does exist and
plate in the sense but since they're
always perfectible and provisional and
we expect that they will be modified by
further advances it's hard to say that
they exist in the same sense as physical
reality or nature or the universe exists
they are always shadows on the wall of
the cave to follow Plato's allegory our
Keeley's also says that he wants to
major in physics and do I have any
advice well my advice is go for it if
you like physics go for it
study hard and broadly learn some math
and work hard if you enjoy doing physics
you'll enjoy studying and preparing
yourself to do research which is the
really fun part
ah go for it it's a great life and a
great way to spend ones time